bonjour david des tests qui se sont donc
avérés concluants en espagne en
allemagne également est ce que la france
donc va franchir le pas selon vous oui
bien magali et c'est en bonne voie en
tout cas puisque dès le mois prochain
des syndicats de producteurs prévoient
des expériences tests sur le modèle de
barcelone et de l'exil
une mobilisation du monde du spectacle
pour sortir la tête de l'eau sur les
mêmes bases
un public volontaire tester avant et
après le rassemblement en février
prochain
un one man show devrait se tenir à la
cigale salle réputée à paris est d'une
capacité de 900 personnes
de concert avec deux mille spectateurs
cobayes sont à l'étude également à
marseille l'objectif est de redonner vie
aux salles de spectacles à l'arrêt
depuis mars 2020 même si jean castex a
prévu de faire un point sur la situation
le 20 janvier prochain
le premier ministre vient donner aucune
indication concernant l'éventuelle
réouverture de ces salles de spectacle
roselyne bachelot elle se dit intéressé
par ce type d'expérience mais se soucie
de d'une certaine logistique écoutez je
trouve ces expériences tout à fait
d'intéressantes et je les suis avec un
grand intérêt
ce que je trouve intéressant c'est la
façon dont ça s'est déroulé tous les
spectateurs ont été testés négatif avant
de rentrer dans la salle
c'est de ça dont nous discutons avec les
acteurs du spectacle vivant de la
logistique à mettre en place
est-ce que cela amènerait à labelliser
des salles qui serait pandémie
compatibles et d'autres qui ne le serait
pas
c'est la question un problème de
logistique à plus grande échelle c'est
effectivement le problème qui pourrait
se poser mais l'espoir est bel et bien
permis et barcelone david semble être la
base de cet espoir
en effet un l'exemple espagnol et le
modèle sur lequel elle les salles
françaises vont s'appuyer pour à ses
futures expériences alors dans le
concret ce qu'on pourrait arriver
pourrait voir arriver en france c'est
avant tout un protocole sanitaire
extrêmement strict afin d'éviter
d'éventuelles contaminations souvient à
barcelone que c'était un peu moins de
500 personnes qui se sont rendues à un
concert organisé dans une salle d'une
capacité de 900 places hormis les tests
négatifs demandé en avant et le port
obligatoire du masque ffp2 et bien
d'autres mesures du protocole c'est
l'optimisation de la ventilation ainsi
que la surveillance de la température
ambiante
lors de l'expérience barcelonaise huit
jours plus tard aucun spectateur n'a été
testé positif au courant d'un virus en
tout cas si le procédé s'avère concluant
et bien ces modèles seront utiles pour
toutes au titre tout autre type de
rassemblements tels que congrès cours de
fac match de foot et dès le mois d'avril
on pourra mettre en perspective ces
perspectives
plusieurs études européennes afin de
voir la lumière au bout du tunnel pour
ces secteurs particulièrement touchés
depuis le début de l'épidémie
merci beaucoup d'avis de khalifa pour
toutes ces précisions